This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这就是当电梯旁边也有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一头走出来。收听《2%》。即数字的2。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。在《回望过去》播客节目中。对1979年来说，那对我和我而言是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回望过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的男性经历，进行在任何其他地方其实都不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的有执照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听并学习《艰难一课》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s and back for another dating episode. I think we all kind of want to know the secret to love, right? The secret not just to finding our person, but also making it last and making the relationship healthy and sustainable. and fulfilling for not just the next few months, but hopefully the next few years, maybe our entire lives. There are a lot of different dating tips, dating advice out there around how exactly to do that. But what I found is that if you really want true long-lasting love, if you want to find somebody in your 20s, in your 30s, whenever you are ready, instead of just rushing into any connection that passes you by, instead of really getting swept up in big romances and big love affairs that burn very, very bright,
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，我们一起剖析20多岁的心理学，并迎来又一期关于约会的节目。我想我们大概都想知道爱的秘密，对吧？这个秘密不仅在于找到我们的真命天子/女，还在于如何让它持久，让关系保持健康、可持续，并且不仅在未来几个月，而且希望在未来几年，甚至我们的一生中都让人感到充实。关于具体该怎么做，有很多不同的约会小贴士和约会建议。但我发现，如果你真的想要真正的、长久的爱，如果你想在20多岁、30多岁、或者任何你准备好的时候找到某个人，而不是仅仅急于投入任何从你身边擦肩而过的感情，而不是真正卷入那些燃烧得非常非常耀眼的宏大浪漫和恋爱之中，
go slow, approach love, approach dating, any of those endeavors as kind of like a scenic drive. You're getting to know them, you're not rushing into things. It is to be, you know, smooth and easy and carefree and fun. And I think that, you know, amongst all the noise and all the dating advice, maybe what we really need is more emotional vulnerability and emotional intimacy, and that definitely comes with time. So today we are going to be talking about just that this approach to dating, the slow manse, the slow burn, low pressure first dates, all of those things. And we are also going to bring on an incredible guest, somebody who knows so much more about
放慢脚步，以一种类似于风景优美驾驶的心态去对待爱情、约会以及任何这些努力。你在了解他们，你并不急于求成。这应该是，你知道的，顺利、轻松、无忧无虑且有趣的。而且我认为，你知道的，在所有的噪音和所有的约会建议中，也许我们真正需要的是更多的情感脆弱性和情感亲密度，而这绝对需要时间来实现。所以今天我们要讨论的正是这一点，这种约会的方法，慢节奏恋爱（slowmance）、慢热（slow burn）、低压力的初次约会，所有这些事情。我们还将请来一位不可思议的嘉宾，一个比我更了解这一点的人，
this than I do, and can provide us some insight. Without further ado, let's get into it. Today we have on the wonderful Mo. They are a licensed marriage and family therapist and the love and connection expert at Hinge to talk about this amazing topic. Can you introduce yourself in a bit of your work? Yay, thank you. That was a beautiful introduction. Thank you so much for having me.
并且可以为我们提供一些见解。废话不多说，我们切入正题。今天我们请到了棒极了的莫。他们是一位持牌婚姻与家庭治疗师，也是Hinge的爱与连接专家，来讨论这个了不起的话题。你能简单介绍一下你自己和你的工作吗？耶，谢谢。这是一个美丽的介绍。非常感谢邀请我。
I am, well, you said I am. I am a licensed marriage and family therapist and the love and connection expert at Hinge. Over the past decade, I've been working with individuals. families, couples, on relationships. So relationships has been my focus of my work. And that spans the life journey. It spans a variety of life experiences. I identify as non-binary transgender.
我是，好吧，你说了我是。我是一位持牌婚姻与家庭治疗师，也是Hinge的爱与连接专家。在过去十年里，我一直与个人、家庭、情侣合作，关注亲密关系。所以亲密关系一直是我工作的重心。这跨越了人生的旅程。它涵盖了各种各样的生活经历。我的自我认同是跨性别非二元性别者。
So I am a part of the LGBTQI plus community. I use they, them, or he, him pronouns. And yeah, I am excited about all of the work I've been doing at Hinge. Basically, what I'm doing at Hinge is pairing all of that experience as a therapist. And I am joining that with Hinges, data-backed insights around dating and relationships to offer Dator's valuable advice on and off of the app about connection and creating meaningful partnership.
所以我也是LGBTQI+社区的一员。我使用they/them或he/him代词。是的，我对我在Hinge所做的一切工作感到非常兴奋。基本上，我在Hinge所做的是将我作为治疗师的所有经验结合起来，并将其与Hinge关于约会和关系的基于数据的洞察相结合，在应用程序内外为约会者提供关于建立连接和有意义的伴侣关系的宝贵建议。
You want to know something interesting? I didn't even know. I don't think I even told you this. I actually met my partner on Hinejave. inch. Wow. So I'm really excited to like get into this because I honestly didn't even, of course I knew how we met, but I hadn't even like clock that there would be that late until just that. So I'm excited to talk about this as well and not just obviously like you you just have this wealth of knowledge from having literal access to our dating data, which is like insane. But also this concept that you talk about a lot of the slow burn and slowmance, which I think is wonderful. Let's actually. address the Hinge's new data report firstly because I get so many questions from people in their 20s being like, what is the correct way to be dating right now? Am I doing this right? Like I want to find the love of my life or I want something more casual and it feels like I just can't
你想知道一件有趣的事吗？我甚至都不知道。我想我甚至都没跟你说过这个。我实际上是在Hinge上认识我的伴侣的。哇。所以我真的很兴奋能深入探讨这个话题，因为老实说我甚至没有——当然我知道我们是怎么认识的，但在刚才那一刻之前，我甚至没有意识到会有那种联系。所以我很高兴能讨论这个，不仅仅是因为你字面意义上拥有我们约会数据的访问权限，因而拥有极其丰富的知识，这太疯狂了。而且还有你经常谈到的慢热（slow burn）和慢节奏恋爱（slowmance）这个概念，我认为这棒极了。让我们首先探讨一下Hinge的新数据报告，因为我从20多岁的人那里听到了太多问题，比如，现在约会正确的做法是什么？我这样做对吗？比如我想找到我一生的挚爱，或者我想要更随意的关系，而我感觉我就是无法
crack the code. So can you explain some of the key findings from this report? Absolutely. I am excited to hear more about how you and your partner made. And so we released very recently our new dating report called the LGBTQI plus date report that stands for data advice, trends, and expertise. And inside of that report, we surveyed many queer daters on our app. And we found that 76% of queer hinge daters say that they wish that they had more positive, healthy examples of relationships when they were growing up. And so we know that there are often these gaps in representation for the queer community. So we're hoping to fill some of that space with more information, support, celebration of queer daters.
破解这个密码。所以你能解释一下这份报告的一些关键发现吗？当然。我很兴奋能听到更多关于你和你的伴侣是如何结缘的。因此，我们最近发布了名为LGBTQI+约会报告的新约会报告，它代表着数据、建议、趋势和专业知识（data, advice, trends, and expertise）。在这份报告中，我们调查了我们应用程序上的许多酷儿约会者。我们发现，76%的酷儿Hinge约会者表示，他们希望在成长过程中能有更多积极、健康的恋爱关系榜样。因此我们知道，酷儿社区的代表性往往存在这些空白。所以我们希望用更多信息、支持和对酷儿约会者的庆祝来填补其中一些空间。
And so I'm really honored to be in this role where I get to take part in that. The number one topic that we found that queer hinged daters want to learn more about is emotional intimacy. So when we think about the foundation of relationship and building long-term, connections, I often think, especially as a therapist, emotional intimacy is central to that. 50% of queer-haged data said that they want to learn how to build trust. And so these core topics, emotional intimacy, trust, not throw in communication, collaboration, all of these things support the foundational relationships. And they're essential to what we're calling at Hinge
所以我真的很荣幸能担任这个角色，参与其中。我们发现酷儿Hinge约会者最想了解的头号话题是情感亲密度。因此，当我们考虑关系的基础和建立长期连接时，我经常认为，特别是作为一个治疗师，情感亲密度是其中的核心。50%的酷儿Hinge约会者表示，他们想学习如何建立信任。因此，这些核心话题——情感亲密度、信任，更不用说沟通、协作了——所有这些都支持着关系的基础。它们对于我们在Hinge上所说的
Slomance. And I'm happy to get even more into that. Yeah. Well, so I want to focus on this first thing. that you said, which is that so many people want more emotional intimacy. And I do feel like the nature of dating in our 20s sometimes, like before I met my partner, it definitely felt like this is a transaction. And especially like I was on the apps. And I think I got kind of very cynical about it for a while, quite cynical because I was like, everything just feels like there is either I want for like something physical immediately or pretty quickly or it's like the same conversations again and again and again that never let go much deeper. And I also think that the reason we kind of hold back emotionally sometimes when we are in that environment is because we have so many like
慢节奏恋爱（slomance）至关重要。我很高兴能更深入地探讨这一点。是的。嗯，所以我想关注你说的第一点，那就是这么多人都想要更多的情感亲密度。而且我确实觉得我们20多岁时的约会本质有时——在我遇到伴侣之前，它绝对让人感觉这是一种交易。尤其是像我在用约会软件的时候。而且我想我有一段时间对它变得非常愤世嫉俗，相当愤世嫉俗，因为我觉得，所有事情都像是要么我立刻或者相当快地想要某种身体上的接触，要么就是一遍又一遍、没完没了重复着那些永远不会更深入的相同对话。而且我还认为，我们在这种环境中时之所以有时会压抑自己的情感，是因为我们有太多的
options, right? And we don't want to get vulnerable with the wrong person. Does that like concern you at all, like what capacity to build long-term relationships? That's a really, really good question. Yeah. What I'm hearing you saying is that there are all of these different worries or challenges that get in the way of us making meaningful connections very early on. So in that, first I was holding so much empathy and space as a therapist, and I hope energetically you felt that.
选择，对吧？我们不想对错误的人变得脆弱。这会不会让你对建立长期关系的能力产生任何担忧？这是一个非常非常好的问题。是的。我听到你说的是，所有这些不同的担忧或挑战阻碍了我们在很早的时候就建立有意义的连接。因此，首先，作为一个治疗师，我怀着极大的同理心和包容心，我希望你在能量上也感受到了这一点。
I know I really did. I feel like, yeah. I think your story and what you're saying relates to how many people are feeling or many of their, many people's experiences. Many people are coming to the table with worries about whether or not they'll be received in a relationship or that someone will like them back. And so I think a lot of what prevents us from showing up authentically, being vulnerable, leaning in, having the seemingly challenging conversations is this desire to be received well. So if we're worried that we'll be rejected, we'll often just prevent ourselves from leaning in. So my advice would be for daters to become really intimately aware of that voice that is creating these narratives inside of us. It's often in our voice.
我知道我真的感受到了。我觉得，是的。我认为你的故事以及你所说的话，与许多人的感受或许多人的经历息息相关。许多人带着对自己在关系中是否会被接纳，或者别人是否会喜欢自己的担忧来到谈判桌前。因此，我认为阻碍我们表现得真实、展现脆弱、倾心投入、进行看似具有挑战性的对话的很大一部分原因，是对被良好接纳的渴望。所以如果我们担心会被拒绝，我们通常就会阻止自己倾心投入。因此我的建议是，让约会者对这种在我们内心创造这些叙事的内在声音产生深刻的、亲密的觉察。它通常是以我们的声音出现的。
But the narrative itself is important because if we're not aware that we're telling ourselves, you're not enough or that we're not enough or that we're, that we're afraid that we won't be enough or that we're afraid that we'll be rejected, like that time we were rejected at high school or whatever the narrative is, then we can't go about changing it. So I often take a narrative approach as a therapist, meaning that I work on shifting the stories that we tell ourselves that often form limiting beliefs that keep us from our goals. And so the first step in that narrative therapy approach is to really
但叙事本身很重要，因为如果我们没有意识到我们在对自己说“你不够好”或者“我们不够好”，或者我们害怕自己不够好，或者我们害怕被拒绝——就像我们在高中时被拒绝的那次，或者无论那是什么叙事——那么我们就无法去改变它。因此，作为一名治疗师，我通常采用叙事方法，这意味着我致力于改变我们对自己讲述的故事，这些故事通常会形成限制性信念，阻碍我们实现目标。因此，叙事治疗方法的第一步，就是真正
get clear on what the narratives are. So that's the first step. And I want that to be people's homework. I don't want you to do anything beyond that. Just like focus on becoming aware of what those narratives are that are preventing vulnerability. And I think when we talk about dating in this day age, just dating in general, sometimes we do mask our emotional intimacy or mask our need for emotional intimacy with physicality. Right? It's like, okay, I can. speed up this relationship physically and it feels exciting and it feels new without ever actually having to connect with this person on a deeper level. And I think that's kind of part of our inclination to just dive straight in to a new relationship. Are you kind of, have you seen that
弄清楚这些叙事是什么。所以这是第一步。我希望这是人们的家庭作业。我不想让你做除此之外的任何事情。就像专注于去意识到那些阻碍脆弱性的叙事是什么一样。而且我认为，当我们谈论当今时代的约会，也就是一般的约会时，有时我们确实用身体接触掩盖了我们的情感亲密度，或者掩盖了我们对情感亲密度的需求。对吧？就像是，好吧，我可以。在身体上加速这段关系，这感觉很令人兴奋，感觉很新鲜，却根本不需要在更深层次上与这个人建立连接。我认为这正是我们倾向于直接一头扎进新关系的一部分原因。你有没有，你有没有见过这种情况
yourself? Like the need to, not to say that like take your, take your time, like do whatever you want. It's your body. It's your choice. But sometimes like, and I will say I noticed this in myself when I was dating it's like okay I don't want to be rejected by you secondly I don't want to get hurt by you and like show myself show myself as a vulnerable individual so if we just like speed up this relationship and just like get straight to the point like I'll never have to get hurt is that something that you've seen absolutely I think what you're getting at is this inclination we have to jump into relationships when we're feeling like someone likes us back. That's how I categorize it.
你自己？比如那种需要——并不是说“花你的时间，做你想做的事。这是你的身体。这是你的选择”——但有时，而且我会说我在自己约会时注意到了这一点，就像是，好吧，我不想被你拒绝，其次，我不想被你伤害，并向你展示自己——作为一个脆弱的个体，所以如果我们只是加速这段关系，直奔主题——我就永远不必受到伤害，这是你见过的情况吗？绝对的。我认为你所指的是我们那种在感觉某人也喜欢我们时就急于跳进一段关系的倾向。我是这样分类的。
And I like to break this down a bit because I think that that's one reason why that's happening. And then I think that there are two other very common reasons why that's occurring. So I guess follow me, if you will, the first one being like, it feels good to be liked back. And I don't know how many people listening to the show can remember Teddy Pendergrass. if you even know who that is. If you do, you probably have baby boomer parents like I do.
我喜欢把这个拆解一下，因为我认为这是发生这种情况的一个原因。然后我认为还有另外两个非常常见的原因导致这种情况发生。所以我想，如果你愿意的话，跟着我的思路来，第一个原因就像是：被人喜欢的感觉很好。我不知道收听节目的有多少人还记得泰迪·彭德格拉斯（Teddy Pendergrass）。如果你甚至知道那是谁的话。如果你知道，你可能和我一样有婴儿潮一代的父母。
But he has this show that's, I'm sorry, he has this song that's called When Somebody Loves You Back. And it's one of my favorite old school songs. But the line goes, it feels good loving somebody when somebody loves you back. And it's just so smooth the way he sings it. But here it's accurate. When you like someone, it just feels good. So I think that that first kind of person that we're thinking about here is a person. who desires their affection to be returned. And so they dive in pretty quickly because they
但他有一场演出，哦抱歉，他有一首歌叫《当某人回爱你》（When Somebody Loves You Back）。这是我最喜欢的老派歌曲之一。但歌词是这样的：“当某人回爱你时，爱某人的感觉真好”。他唱歌的方式实在是太流畅了。但在这里它是准确的。当你喜欢某人时，感觉就是很好。所以我认为我们在这里考虑的第一种人是这样一个人，
desire that feedback, those signs that they're, that person's into them. And I think what they really want is reciprocity. And some of the ways in which we can slow the relationship down to get that reciprocity is to have those conversations about how the person, the other person feels, initiate those conversations rather than just kind of trying to ride the wave of emotions that kind of takes the relationship at top speed. I think the second kind of person that shows up, in my opinion, is a person that has those fears of rejection that we were talking about. So a person might show up with these fears around rejection, but really what I think they want
他们渴望自己的感情得到回报。所以他们相当快地投入其中，因为他们渴望那种反馈，渴望对方也迷恋他们的迹象。而我认为他们真正想要的是互惠。我们可以通过放慢关系节奏来获得这种互惠的方法之一，就是进行关于对方、另一个人感受的对话，主动发起这些对话，而不是仅仅试图乘风破浪，让关系以最高速度发展。我认为出现的第二种在我看来是这样的人，是一个有我们刚才谈到的对拒绝恐惧的人。所以一个人可能会带着对拒绝的恐惧出现，但实际上我认为他们真正想要的是
is some type of safety or security. And the way that we can slow relationships down for people who are having the security need is to have those initial conversations pretty early on about what. where things are headed. So that means we can maybe initiate a conversation and say, hey, so, you know, at what point in your dating journey do you typically have conversations about what are we? Like when do you have the what are we conversation? It could be very general. I do not suggest saying very early on, what are we? I am saying have a general conversation that can slow things down and make it a co-creation around the relationship future versus leaving that up to chance or
某种安全感。对于有安全感需求的人，我们可以通过在早期就初步探讨未来发展方向来放慢关系节奏。这意味着我们可以发起对话并说：“嘿，那么，你知道的，在你约会旅程的哪个阶段，你通常会讨论‘我们算什么关系’？就像你什么时候会进行‘我们算什么关系’的对话？”这可以是很通用的。我绝对不建议在很早的时候就说“我们算什么关系？”我的意思是进行一次通用的对话，它可以放慢节奏，并在关系未来上实现共同创造，而不是将其留给运气，或者
leaving it to being one person's responsibility. And then the third person that I like to think about when I think about rushing in pretty quickly is a person who's just trying to go with the flow. I think go with the flow people in this regard are worried about making things too complicated. And often I think that they have a need around authenticity. They want the other person to be themselves and they want to be received for being themselves. And so by going with the flow, they think they're accomplishing this. I think the risk here is that we can ignore our own authenticity and what we want in terms of pacing and timing because we're afraid to have a
留给某一个人的责任。然后，当我想到急于投入的人时，我想到的第三种人是那种只想顺其自然的人。我认为在这方面随波逐流的人担心把事情搞得太复杂。而且通常我认为他们对真实性有需求。他们希望另一个人做自己，并希望因为做自己而被接纳。因此，通过随波逐流，他们认为自己实现了这一点。我认为这里的风险在于，我们可能会忽视我们自己的真实性，忽视我们在节奏和时机方面的需求，因为我们害怕发生
conflict or afraid to speak up. So I typically encourage daters to slow things down with and they're experiencing this by having necessary conversations around the relationship through ease and compassion. If we want there to be ease in the relationship, and that's our primary desire, keep going with the flow in how you're having the conversation. Be compassionate, be easy, be too in the conversation while still being vulnerable and open-hearted.
冲突或害怕说出来。所以我通常鼓励约会者通过轻松和富有同情心的必要关系对话来放慢节奏并体验这一点。如果我们希望关系中存在轻松感，而这是我们的首要愿望，那么在你们对话的方式上继续保持随波逐流。保持同情心，保持轻松，在对话中保持融入，同时仍然保持脆弱和敞开心扉。
And I think that accomplishes what we're really trying to get at. So I know I said a lot there, but I hope that everybody has their three people in mind and that they're checking where they are on that in that. You definitely said a lot, but you said a lot that was like all of it was so helpful. And you know what I really resonated with when you were saying that was also like the individual who was anxiously attached, right? When there are signs that someone is pulling away and might be putting distance between you and them for whatever reason. and maybe they are busy at work. Maybe they are trying to protect themselves, trying to, you know, not get hurt.
我认为这实现了我们真正想要达到的目标。所以我知道我刚才说了很多，但我希望每个人心里都有他们对应的三种人，并且他们正在对照检查自己在其中的位置。你确实说了很多，但你说的很多话都——所有这些都太有帮助了。你知道当你说到那些时我真正共鸣的是什么吗，也是那种焦虑型依恋的个体，对吧？当有迹象表明某人正在疏远，并且由于某种原因可能在你和他们之间保持距离时。也许他们在工作上很忙。也许他们正试图保护自己，试图，你知道的，不受到伤害。
We tend to become quite clingy. And we tend to like, the more they try and pull away, the more we try and pull them closer, which inevitably ends up kind of backfiring, right? Right? Like it's, I also think that's part of the inclination to really speed up relationships is, I want this person to fall in love with me as soon as possible
我们往往会变得非常黏人。而且我们往往会这样，他们越是想退缩，我们就越是想把他们拉得更近，这不可避免地会适得其反，对吧？对吧？就像是，我也觉得这也是急于推进感情的倾向的一部分，我希望这个人能尽快爱上我
so that we're out of this weird, awkward stage where I don't feel like I can trust them, where I don't have a label, where I don't have commitment, and all of those things leave me vulnerable to being hurt. So I think at the end of the day, like, that all of it comes down to, I don't want to be hurt,
这样我们就能走出这个奇怪、尴尬的阶段，在这个阶段里我觉得无法信任他们，没有名分，没有承诺，所有这些都让我容易受到伤害。所以我觉得归根结底，这一切都归结为，我不想受到伤害，
I want my needs met, and perhaps I like the feeling of being loved back. And so like, let's get to that point. as soon as possible. And I also liked what you said about having a conversation. So I'll talk about my partner, Tom, in this instance. When we first met, I had just had like a string of, of relationships in which there was no commitment. And we talk about, you know, the slowmance, which we'll get to in a second. And there is a difference between going slow and also having absolutely no idea what is on. Absolutely. You know what I mean? And like the timeline just being like what this neither ends or
我希望我的需求得到满足，也许我喜欢被爱的感觉。所以，让我们尽快达到那个阶段吧。我也很喜欢你刚才说的关于进行对话的事情。所以我在这时会谈谈我的伴侣汤姆。我们刚认识时，我刚经历了一连串没有承诺的感情。我们谈论了，你知道的，慢节奏恋爱，我们一会儿会聊到这个。慢慢来和完全不知道发生了什么之间是有区别的。当然。你知道我的意思吗？就像时间线感觉既没有结束也没有
begins. So you know what I mean? And I think that when I met him, I was so, um, so aware and so worried about that happening again. And I also kind of knew that if I was to be like, so what are we like within two dates? There was a good chance that he was going to be like, okay, this girl has absolutely no chill and flee, which I totally got. And so I think it was like around our fifth or sixth date. And I actually remember where it was. We were in Bondi in Sydney and we were eating sushi at a sushi train. And instead of asking the question like, what are we?
开始。所以你知道我的意思吗？我觉得当我遇到他时，我是如此地，嗯，如此清楚并担心这种情况会再次发生。而且我也隐约知道，如果我在约会两次后就说，那我们算什么？他很有可能会觉得，好吧，这个女孩一点也不冷静，然后逃跑，这我完全理解。所以我想那大概是在我们的第五次或第六次约会时。我甚至还记得当时在哪里。我们在悉尼的邦迪，在一个回转寿司店吃寿司。我没有问“我们算什么？”这个问题，
I simply was like, this is what I'm looking for. And I'm not asking you to tell me what you feel about that. I'm not asking you to give me an answer. I'm just saying like it's up to you. This is, I'm going to give you the full information. I'm looking for something serious. I really like you. I think this is going amazingly well.
我只是简单地说，这就是我在寻找的。我不是要求你告诉我你对此有什么感觉。我不是要求你给我一个答案。我只是说，这取决于你。这就是，我要把完整的信息告诉你。我在寻找一段认真的感情。我真的很喜欢你。我觉得这一切进展得不可思议。好。
And if you don't think that way, if that's like not something that we're on the same page on, maybe like we should rethink. And he didn't give me an answer straight away. And yes, that made me anxious. But he was like, he was like, listen, like I am really up to seeing where this goes. I obviously really like you.
如果你不这么想，如果我们在这方面没有共识，也许我们应该重新考虑。他没有立刻给我答案。是的，这让我很焦虑。但他当时说，他当时说，听着，我是真的很想看看这会发展成什么样。我显然也很喜欢你，
But I don't want to put too much pressure on it right now. Is that okay? Can I think about it? And I was like, yeah, of course you can think about it. And, you know, flash forward, we're still together and like very much in love. So I think that what would you say to people who are like, if I ask too soon, if I want some form of confirmation, if I need some form of confirmation, the relationship might end. What would you say to that? Yeah. Well, one, your story is like very powerful because there, you're. it's the imagery that's coming to mind is the idea that having that conversation didn't create this a period on the relationship. It wasn't like you offered what you want and then you were just done with him because he didn't want the same things. There was like this comma. There's like this
但我现在不想给它太大压力。这样可以吗？我可以考虑一下吗？然后我说，可以，你当然可以考虑。而且，你知道，快进到现在，我们依然在一起，而且非常相爱。所以我想，对于那些认为“如果我问得太早，如果我想要某种确认，如果我需要某种确认，感情可能会结束”的人，你会对他们说些什么？是的。嗯，首先，你的故事非常有力量，因为在那里，你。浮现在脑海中的意象是，进行那次对话并没有给感情画上句号。这并不像你表达了你想要什么，然后因为他不想要相同的东西你就甩了他。这就像是一个逗号。就像有一个
end that's interjected and you keep going with the story and now you all have been together. And so if I'm offering any advice, it's really to do a lot more of what you did, which is to create that space for that conversation, to allow it to be ongoing. It doesn't have to be this one-time thing. I think that's often how it's presented in the world or in movies that you kind of say, what are we? People say, yes or no, and that's it. But it's not a yes or no. It's like more great than that. Like love is more complex than that. I can't really relate to this story. I can relate to the first time I asked my now wife to be my girlfriend.
句号被插入，然后你继续着你们的故事，现在你们一直在一起。所以如果要我给出什么建议，那就是多做一些你所做的事情，也就是为对话创造空间，让它能够持续进行。它不必是一次性的事情。我认为这通常是世界上或电影中呈现的方式，你问，我们算什么？人们说是或不是，然后就结束了。但这并不是一个是非题。它比那更宏大。爱比那更复杂。我其实对这个故事感同身受。我能理解我第一次请求现在成为我妻子的她做我女朋友时的情景。
And she was like, ask me again in the morning. Like she didn't feel like she was, she had clarity in the moment. So she's like, ask me in the morning. And this actually came up again when I asked her to marry me. She was like, yes, but not right now. And I was like kind of devastated in the moment because I had only known it's a yes or a no. And so we went to therapy in one session, the therapist is like, you know, you can just have a long engagement. And that opened my mind to this comma where there was a period. I'm thinking
她说，早上再问我一次。就像她觉得她没有，她当时没有理清头绪。所以她说，早上问我吧。而这在我向她求婚时又发生了。她说，好，但不是现在。当时我有点心碎，因为我只知道答案要么是“是”要么是“不”。于是我们去做了心理咨询，在其中一次咨询中，治疗师说，你知道的，你们可以订婚久一点。这让我的思维豁然开朗，看到了一个原本以为是句号的地方其实是一个逗号。我在想，
we're going to have to end our relationship and the therapist is going to tell me, yeah, you know, she's not the one. And now we've been together. Our dating anniversary is going to be 10 years come like October 31st. And so it's been a long time of like commas and ends. And so my advice for anyone around having these conversations is that they really enrich the relationship. They build this really strong foundation for your relationship future. If you lean in, if you allow yourself to be vulnerable, and if you allow yourself to keep having the conversation, because it's not a period. I absolutely adore that.
我们可能要结束这段感情了，治疗师会告诉我，是的，你知道的，她不是对的人。现在我们已经在一起了。到10月31日，我们的恋爱纪念日就满10年了。所以这是一段充满逗号和句号的长久历程。因此，我给任何想要进行这些对话的人的建议是，它们真的能丰富感情。它们为你们未来的感情奠定了非常坚实的基础。如果你投入其中，如果你允许自己变得脆弱，如果你允许自己不断地进行对话，因为它不是一个句号。我绝对太喜欢这个了。
Like the idea that the timeline needs to be linear and consecutive and like, okay, so we're dating and then you're my girlfriend or my boyfriend or my partner. And then, okay, to his time. And there cannot be any hesitation in that time. And there cannot be any moments of needing to maybe slow things down or to actually think about things. And I'm sure people are listening to this being like, no, you know, if you know, you know. No, I love your earlier example of how there need to be boundaries because you know, there could be scenarios where, you know, there, you said there was no starter, no end. I love it you said that because some relationships can feel like they don't have any time bound.
就像这种时间线必须是线性的、连续的想法，比如，好吧，我们在约会，然后你成了我的女朋友或男朋友或伴侣。然后，好吧，到了这个时候。在那段时间里不能有任何犹豫。不能有任何需要放慢节奏或实际思考的时刻。我确信听这段话的人会觉得，不，你知道的，如果懂了就是懂了。不，我喜欢你刚才的例子，关于为什么需要有边界，因为你知道，可能会出现这样的情况，你知道，你刚才说没有开始，也没有结束。我很高兴你这么说，因为有些感情会让人觉得它们没有任何时间限制。
at all. And I certainly think in those instances it's important to get clear on if you're even working toward the same things, if you even want the same things. But in these, in these scenarios, it's a matter of timing. I think you'll know that by having the conversation. No, exactly. I completely agree. And also, I think that everyone's relationship is different, right? And sometimes I think I'm scared for the people who experience that really fast intensity, like hyper intense early days. And the saying is always like what burns brightest, burns out quickest. I think that's the way to go.
一点也没有。我当然认为在这些情况下，弄清楚你们是否在朝着相同的事情努力，你们是否甚至想要相同的东西是很重要的。但在这些，在这些情况下，这是一个时机的问题。我想通过对话你会明白这一点的。不，完全如此。我完全同意。而且，我也认为每个人的感情都是不同的，对吧？有时我想，我很为那些经历那种极其迅速的强烈情感、超强烈早期阶段的人感到担心。有句老话说得好，燃烧最旺的，熄灭得也最快。我想这才是正确的方式。
And I think our society has very much sold us this idea of romantic love as being this like, when you know you know thing, you're immediately like, I saw this quote the other day. It's like when you see them in your future, you want the future to start right now. This idea of like passion and intensity and like attraction. And yes, of course I want to move in with you. And of course I want to fall in love and let's have children. But what are the benefits that you have seen? What are the benefits for the longevity and the sustainability and the health of a relationship
而且我认为我们社会非常向往浪漫爱情的这种理念，就像那种“懂了就是懂了”的事情，你立刻就会，我前几天看到这样一句话。就像当你看到你们的未来时，你希望未来现在就开始。这种激情、强烈和吸引力的理念。是的，当然我想和你搬到一起住。当然我想坠入爱河，让我们生孩子吧。但你看到了哪些好处？对于一段感情的持久性、可持续性和健康，有哪些好处
from embracing a slowmance from kind of slowing it down, not going with the flow, but just letting, taking the scenic route, let's say it that way. Yeah, it's a beautiful and powerful, poignant question. When we think about longevity and relationships, I really believe that the foundation of relationship is a, it looks a lot like friendship. There's a lot of, there are a lot of those qualities there, this good communication, this intimacy around the emotionality, the safety, the space holding, the empathy,
通过拥抱慢节奏恋爱，也就是放慢脚步，不是随波逐流，而是让，选择走风景优美的路线，我们可以这样说。是的，这是一个美丽、强大而又深刻的问题。当我们思考感情的持久性时，我真的相信感情的基础是，它看起来非常像友谊。那里有许多，有许多这样的特质，良好的沟通，围绕情感的亲密感，安全感，提供支持的空间，同理心，
we could just keep going on and on. That's what we need for our relationships to grow and expand over time. Otherwise, we have relationships that are stagnant, conflictual, and stubborn, not growing, not changing. So when we think about why slowmance is so important, it's because it allows for us to take the time
我们可以一直说下去。这正是我们的关系随着时间推移而成长和扩展所需要的。否则，我们的关系就会停滞不前、充满冲突和顽固，无法成长，无法改变。所以当我们思考为什么慢节奏恋爱如此重要时，是因为它让我们有时间
necessary to build those foundational skills necessary for long-term partnership. we were not born with a manual for how to be the best partner to our partners, let alone like ourselves. We're learning self-love, usually all together collectively. And we were not even born with a manual for that. So we're not, we don't have a manual for how to be the best partner. So we are learning as we grow and these foundational, these foundational things that we're building through slowmance, but through taking our time, through prioritizing humor and building rapport and focusing on levity in the relationship early on,
建立长期伴侣关系所必需的基础技能。我们出生时并没有一本关于如何成为伴侣的最佳伴侣的手册，更不用说对自己了。我们在学习自爱，通常是所有人一起集体学习。我们甚至连一本关于这个的手册都没有。所以我们没有，我们没有一本关于如何成为最好伴侣的手册。所以我们在成长中不断学习，这些基础的，我们通过慢节奏恋爱正在建设的基础事物，但通过花时间，通过优先考虑幽默、建立融洽关系并在早期关注关系中的轻松愉快，
gives us a nice cushion for all the stuff that life throws at us along the way. Because your partner and you clearly had this foundation for communication really early on in your relationship, you could have that conversation and say, you know what, this is what I want. and you felt comfortable to do so and he felt comfortable being honest. I think that is a show that you all have created this space for integrity in your relationship
为生活沿途抛给我们的一切提供了很好的缓冲。因为你的伴侣和你很早就为你们关系的沟通奠定了这个基础，你可以进行那次对话并说，你知道吗，这就是我想要的。你感到这样做很舒服，他也觉得坦诚相待很舒服。我认为这表明你们都为你们的关系创造了这个充满正直的空间，
and that is really essential for anyone to make it long term. So Slomance really creates the space for us to do that intentional work without being distracted by where we're going to be 20 years from now or getting really deep, really fast. Oh my God.
这对于任何人走得长远都是至关重要的。所以慢节奏恋爱真的为我们创造了空间，让我们能够进行这种有意的努力，而不会被我们20年后会在哪里或者进展得太快太深所分心。噢天哪。
I absolutely, I'm just like nodding my head to every single thing that you're saying, right? Oh. Yes, that's correct. That's correct. I also think that you kind of want to know that you actually are compatible with them, right? Like that's the other big thing. Like I always say this on the show, but chemistry doesn't equal compatibility. There are so.
我绝对，我只是在对你说的每一句话疯狂点头，对吧？哦。是的，这是对的。这是对的。我也觉得你其实是想知道你们是否真的合拍，对吧？就像那是另一个大问题。就像我总是在节目里说的，化学反应不等于默契。有很多。
Very true. Yeah, there are so many people that of course you're going to have like an amazing spark with. Of course they're going to look like, of course you're going to be attracted to them. but is that the same as if this is what you want being able to build a life with them also like those I don't know about you but those early days in a relationship I still think back on them and think they were so wonderful and having all those yeah having all those firsts and having all those like moments of like exploration and we're getting to know each other and every story he tells you or they tell you is is a new story and it's just like and it's so.
千真万确。是的，有很多人，你当然会跟他们产生惊人的火花。他们当然会看起来，你当然会被他们吸引。但这和如果这就是你想要的、能够与他们共度一生是一回事吗？还有，那些，我不知道你怎么样，但在恋爱的那头几天，我至今想起来仍觉得它们是那么美好，拥有所有那些，是的，拥有所有那些第一次，拥有所有那些探索的时刻，我们在了解彼此，他或他们对你讲的每一个故事都是一个新的故事，而且就像是，它是如此
fun and like you go to the movies together and like they like touch your leg for the first time and you're like a teenager again like there's so much beauty and joy in enjoying those moments rather than trying to speed things up like is that something that you found as well oh absolutely there's one there's this dreamy quality to how you're describing it and i love it because i really have found with working with a lot of couples over the years well actually a lot of people in all kinds of relationship configurations that those early memories, those early conversations, like all of that connection you're talking about really do serve as this cushion for the relationship later. So if I imagine me sitting in a room with two people, two other people who are in this constant
有趣，就像你们一起去看电影，然后他们第一次摸了你的腿，你就像个青少年一样，享受这些时刻有着如此多的美丽和快乐，而不是试图加速事情的发展，这也是你所发现的吗？哦，绝对是的。你描述的方式有一种梦幻般的特质，我非常喜欢，因为我真的通过多年来与许多伴侣合作发现，或者说实际上是与各种关系配置中的许多人合作发现，那些早期的记忆，那些早期的对话，就像你谈论的所有那些连接，确实在后来成为了这段关系的缓冲。所以，如果我想象自己和一个房间里的两个人坐在一起，另外两个在关系中处于持续
conflict in their relationship. And I take a moment, they could have been arguing for 30 minutes in my office. I take a moment and I just ask them to think about why they got together. Like, tell me why you all got together in the first place. I might say something sassy like that to try to change the energy. And usually the thought of why we got together in the first place brings smiles. It brings laughter. It brings joy.
冲突中的人。我花点时间，他们可能已经在我的办公室里争论了30分钟。我花点时间，让他们想想他们为什么在一起。比如，告诉我你们当初为什么在一起。我可能会说一些这样厚脸皮的话来试图改变能量。通常，回想我们当初为什么在一起会带来微笑。它会带来欢笑。它会带来快乐。
Because quite often people associate so much positivity and warmth with those early relationship beginnings. So when we think about slumance, again, It's important that we're prioritizing, savoring that, capturing as much of that as possible, being present to it, not being distracted, really leaning in with an open heart because that time passes and eventually you get to doing life and all of the other things. And it's just so meaningful to have that saved somewhere in your memory so you can access it when times get hard. That is such a beautiful sentiment.
因为很多时候，人们将如此多的积极性和温暖与那些感情的初期联系在一起。所以当我们再次思考慢节奏恋爱时，重要的是我们要优先考虑，品味这一点，尽可能多地捕捉到它，活在当下，不被分心，真正怀着一颗开放的心投入其中，因为时间会流逝，最终你会去过日子以及所有其他事情。把那些保存在记忆里的某个地方是多么有意义啊，这样当困难时期到来时你就可以调取它。这真是一个美丽的观点。
And you know what? I'm going to steal that advice and use it for everyone who ever comes to me with relationship problems. Like why did you why did you even start dating in the first place? Like why are you together? There's usually a good reason and usually the things that they're complaining about
你知道吗？我要把这个建议偷过来，用在每一个来找我寻求情感问题的人身上。比如你们当初为什么开始约会？比如你们为什么在一起？通常都有一个很好的理由，而且通常他们抱怨的事情
are things that they loved before or there were things that were there from the beginning but they found some way of empathizing with those things early on that they can access again. Have you ever heard of this theory called Fatal Attraction Theory? I have not heard of the theory.
是他们以前喜欢的事情，或者是一开始就在那里的事情，但他们早期对这些事情找到某种产生共鸣的方式，使他们能够再次调用。你听说过一种叫做“致命吸引力”的理论吗？我没听说过这个理论。
I've heard of the concept. Tell me more. Okay, so basically this theory, it was proposed by this woman back in like the 90s. And essentially what she says, this woman, I should say, she's a doctor, PhD. So I'm going to check myself there. She's just a girl. No, she's a well-educated lady. And she basically was observing these relationships amongst people that she was seeing on a college campus. And what she was observing was that and amongst her.
我听说过这个概念。多跟我讲讲。好的，所以基本上这个理论，它是由一个女性在90年代左右提出的。基本上她所说的是，这个女性，我应该这么说，她是一位博士，PhD。所以我得纠正一下自己。她可不仅是个普通女孩。不，她是一位受过良好教育的女士。她基本上一直在观察大学校园里她所看到的人们之间的这些关系。她所观察到的是，在她周围的人群中。
own friends and all that. And what she was observing was actually the reason that we end up breaking up with somebody is normally due to something that we first really loved. And it's called the fatal attractor. So, you know, you love that your partner is so like spontaneous and you love that they like, um, are always, you know, surprising you with things and that they really go with the flow and you love that about them, that energy. But then later on, you're like, well, actually, no, I want. So where are we going to dinner tonight? Like, I have work. I need to know the time. And they're like, oh, wherever, like, let's just be spontaneous. It's like, no, this is actually like detrimental to our relationship. Or, you know, you really like the person who is
朋友等等。她所观察到的是，我们最终和某人分手的原因，通常正是我们最初非常喜欢对方的某个特点。这被称为“致命吸引力”。所以，你知道的，你喜欢你的伴侣那么随性，你喜欢他们总是用各种事情给你惊喜，他们真的很随性，你喜欢他们身上的那种活力。但后来，你却会想，其实，不，我想。所以我们今晚去哪吃晚饭？比如，我要工作。我需要知道时间。而他们却说，哦，随便吧，我们就随性一点。这就好比，不，这实际上对我们的关系有害。或者说，你知道的，你真的很喜欢那种人……
really into like work and you like that they're so motivated and you like that they're so focused, but actually that ends up meaning that they spend a lot less time with you. And so that's like exactly what I'm hearing in what you're saying is so often. Like, yes, the thing that we often struggle with most later on is something that has always been there. And it's about being like, okay, but there was something in that that that I loved. There was something in that that really drew me to them. And if you don't have that slow start, how are you going to have taken the time to have processed that? You know what I mean?
非常投入工作，你喜欢他们那么有动力，你喜欢他们那么专注，但实际上这最终意味着他们花在你身上的时间要少得多。所以这正是我从你所说的话中听到的，非常常见。就像，是的，我们后来最常挣扎的事情，往往是那种一直都存在的东西。这就像是，好吧，但其中确实有某种东西是我所喜爱的。其中确实有某种东西真正吸引了我。如果你没有那种缓慢的开始，你又怎么会花时间去消化这些呢？你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. It's so important. I love, thank you for sharing the Fidel Attraction Theory. And I love thinking about this idea of really getting to know someone, getting a full picture of who they are. A lot of times when we're meeting a person, we have a lot of expectations about who they'll be. If people are honest, many people come to relationships with some type of list these days or some type of expectations or desires.
是的。这太重要了。我很高兴，谢谢你分享“致命吸引力理论”。我喜欢这种去真正了解某人、获得他们全貌的想法。很多时候，当我们遇到一个人时，我们对他们会成为什么样的人抱有很高的期望。如果人们诚实的话，现在很多人带着某种清单或某种期望和愿望进入恋爱关系。
And I think that on the head, that's totally fine. Sometimes where that is difficult is that we'll have these expectations about who a person should be for us or we need them to fit these categories or check these boxes and that sometimes prevents us from actually seeing them for who they are. Even if they match all of the boxes that we want them to check, who are they as like a soul, as an individual as a being? What makes them smile? What makes them sad?
我认为说到点子上了，这完全没问题。有时候这之所以困难，是因为我们会对一个人应该成为什么样的人抱有期望，或者我们需要他们符合这些类别或勾选这些方框，而这有时会阻止我们真正看清他们的本来面目。即使他们符合我们想要勾选的所有方框，作为一个灵魂、作为一个人、作为一个生命，他们究竟是谁？什么能让他们微笑？什么能让他们伤心？
Like we don't know those things usually by just, you know, meeting the qualifications of where they went to school and all of these other things. And so it's really important for us to really look at a person, get to know them in a genuine way and an authentic way. Oh, yeah, again, agree, agree, agree. I'm just full of like positive statements about this. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
就像我们通常不知道这些事情一样，仅仅通过了解他们毕业于哪所学校以及所有这些其他事情是不行的。因此，对我们来说，真正审视一个人，以真诚和真实的方式去了解他们，是非常重要的。哦，是的，再次同意，同意，同意。我满脑子都是关于这方面的积极言论。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的科学、健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家对话，还有更多……
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
以此来摒弃主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
收听《2%》。这就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。你还记得琳达·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击金·卡戴珊的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟……
to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔探讨80年代快克可卡因的节目。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在还有艾滋病这个话题。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个世界上活着的时候做一个好人很重要。你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你真正做一个好人。和我一起，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中的惊人矛盾。这就开启了长达数年的法律诉讼来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini.
你伪造了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了一大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名同性恋者，以及迈克尔·马林奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。
So let's move on to something practical because I feel like we've talked a lot about the theory in a lot about like a bit in the clouds a little bit. I love it. Yeah, me too. It's kind of nice. I do appreciate it. But how is it that we can really have a soft start when it feels so unnatural to slow things down? How do we embrace? How do we embrace that need to have a slow burn to go slow?
那我们接下来谈点实际的吧，因为我觉得我们讨论了很多理论，而且有点太空中楼阁了。我喜欢。是的，我也是。这挺不错的。我很感激。但是，当我们觉得放慢节奏很不自然时，我们究竟该如何才能有一个温和的开始呢？我们该如何拥抱？我们该如何拥抱那种需要慢热、需要慢慢来的需求呢？
Yeah. So some of my advice when I'm meeting someone initially, let's say you met them on the hinge. Some of my advice initially is to prioritize humor in those early conversations because our focus early on is connection. We want to, so the first thing I'll say is humor because humor really is disarming. It builds rapport. And rapport is essential for someone to feel comfortable around us, comfortable opening up. Second, I'll say it's important to prioritize sharing your ideals and values with someone early on. People want to have things in common with the people that they're getting to know.
好的。所以当我最初遇到某个人时，比方说你们是在Hinge上认识的，我的一些建议是，在早期对话中优先考虑幽默感，因为我们早期的重点是建立连接。我们想要，所以我首先要说的是幽默，因为幽默确实能打破坚冰，它能建立融洽的关系。而融洽的关系对于让某人在我们身边感到舒适、舒适地敞开心扉至关重要。其次，我会说，在早期与某人分享你的理想和价值观是很重要的。人们希望与他们正在了解的人有共同点。
So if you can prioritize sharing those things on your profile or even in your early communication, I think you have a better chance of really one displaying yourself authentically, but also allowing another person to see you early on. And think the third thing that I'd like people to prioritize when, when engaging in a soft start is lightness and levity. Now, I want when you think light or lightness or levity, I want you to think soft for real. Don't think shallow because the goal is still to be deep.
因此，如果你能在你的个人资料中，甚至在早期的沟通中优先分享这些事情，我认为你更有可能真正一方面展现真实的自己，另一方面也能让另一个人在早期就能看清你。我认为我想让人们在进行温和的开始时优先考虑的第三件事是轻松和轻快。现在，我希望当你想到轻松或轻快时，你要真正地想到“柔和”。不要认为是肤浅，因为我们的目标仍然是深刻。
There's nothing wrong with being deep. We don't want to be so deep where we're saying in that initial conversation with someone, why did your last relationship end? We want to still be deep in the, like, in a, you know, seeing you made me really smile today like in a very genuine and vulnerable way so there are ways to be deep that are not deep on the trauma by the end you know it's like deep in a very grounded and present way like i also think it's about steering away from things that you'll get to eventually and yeah spending a lot of time on the things that people kind of
深刻并没有错。我们不想表现得那么深刻，以至于在与某人的最初对话中就问：“你的上一段感情是怎么结束的？”我们仍然希望在某种深刻中，比如，在一种非常真诚和脆弱的方式中，觉得“你今天让我笑得很开心”，所以有许多深刻的方式并不是以心理创伤为代价的，你知道的，这就好比以一种非常脚踏实地和当下存在的方式来保持深刻——我也认为，这是关于避开那些你最终会谈到的事情，是的，把很多时间花在那些人们有点……
of rush past, right? Like, okay, like, what are your hobbies? You know, like on a first date. People are always like, oh, what are your hobbies? Oh, yeah, I like boxing and I like running. Okay, that's really cool. And what do you do for? And it's like, okay, we speak past that. And if you go, oh my God, so when was your first boxing class? Why do you like that so much? Like, is there something, do you really like expressing yourself physically? That kind of, that feels like a come on, to be honest. But you know what I'm, but you know what I'm. But you know what to be flirty. Yeah. Accidental. And that kind of is. It's like, spend more time getting deep about the things that feel shallow is like what I'm
会匆忙掠过的事情上，对吧？比如，好吧，比如，你的爱好是什么？你知道的，就像在第一次约会上一样。人们总是会问，哦，你的爱好是什么？哦，是的，我喜欢拳击，我喜欢跑步。好吧，这真的很酷。那你平时做什么？这就好像，好吧，我们略过了这些。如果你接着说，哦天哪，那你第一次上拳击课是什么时候？你为什么那么喜欢它？比如，是不是有什么原因，你真的很喜欢通过身体来表达自己？那种感觉，老实说，有点像在调情。但你知道我在……但你知道我在说什么。但你知道怎么去调情。是的。偶然的。而这某种程度上就是。这就好像，花更多的时间去深入探讨那些感觉肤浅的事情，这就是我听到的……
hearing you saying. The other thing, like, I was reflecting on it. And honestly, I was reflecting on in the sense that I did this wrong. Maybe not wrong, but I definitely made this mistake. Don't sacrifice your independent life too quickly. And don't, don't, I get the feeling of being like, I want to see you every day. I want to, I want to, of course, I want to go on a date with you every night. out of the week. I want you to stay over. But if you're like canceling plans with your friends to do that,
你的意思。另一件事，就像，我一直在反思它。老实说，我反思它是觉得我在这方面做错了。也许不算错，但我确实犯了这个错误。不要太快牺牲你的独立生活。不要，不要，我能理解那种感觉，比如“我想每天都见到你。我想要，我当然想一周七天每天晚上都和你约会。我想要你留宿”。但是如果你为了做到这一点而取消了与朋友的计划，
if you're leaving things early to do that, I think what that indicates to me. And I will say, I'm guilty of doing that when I first started dating Tom. I did that all the, not all the time, but there were definitely moments I had to catch myself. And I think what that ends up happening, what ends up occurring as a result of that is that pretty quickly they're everything. They consume all other dimensions of who you are because, you know, your friends are only going to be responsive to you cancelling plans so many times. They're only going to invite you so many times if you ditch them to go and hang out with this person that you met like three weeks ago on a dating out. Right. And so I think that it's about, and I say this all the time, like you,
如果你为了做到这一点而提前离开聚会，我认为这向我表明了什么。而且我得说，当我刚开始和汤姆约会时，我也犯过这样的错。我一直都这么做，也不是一直，但确实有几次我不得不克制自己。我认为最终发生的事情，作为结果出现的事情是，很快他们就成了你的一切。他们占据了你作为一个人的所有其他维度，因为，你知道的，你的朋友对你取消计划的包容度是有限的。如果你为了去和这个你在约会软件上认识三周的人鬼混而抛弃他们，他们只会邀请你有限的次数。对吧。所以我觉得这是关于，我一直都在这么说，就像你……
you can't be a partner without being a person and you have to maintain those like individual parts of yourself. Do you have any other advice on how to do that? in the early days. I think my advice when we're in those early stages is to have fun. I really, I'm stuck on what you're saying, though, because I'm like, yeah, that actually needs to be like number one. Scoot that to the top of the list, not losing yourself in that. It takes time to integrate people into our lives. It takes time for them to become like a steady person in a very intentional and grounded way. So I totally agree. Then I think fun. is really important. So I want to
不作为一个独立的人，你就无法成为一个伴侣，你必须保持你身上的那些个人部分。对于在早期如何做到这一点，你还有什么其他建议吗？我认为当处于那些早期阶段时，我的建议是去玩得开心。不过，我还是对你刚才说的话念念不忘，因为我在想，是的，那实际上需要成为第一位。把它挪到清单的最顶部，不要在其中迷失自我。将人们融入我们的生活需要时间。要让他们以一种非常刻意和脚踏实地的方式成为一个稳定的人，是需要时间的。所以我完全同意。然后我认为乐趣真的很重要。所以我想……
scoot that up to the top of the list. Remembering to have fun especially when so many people are experiencing burnout or so many people are struggling in relationships, fun can really be
把这一点提到清单的最顶部。记得去享受乐趣，尤其是当这么多人正在经历职业倦怠，或者这么多人正在恋爱关系中苦苦挣扎时，乐趣确实可以……
can really infuse the early relationship with the kind of connection that takes it to the next level. Sometimes what we're missing in our connections is fun. We forget that dating, like, yes, it's a big important thing in our life, but it's supposed to be adding to our lives and not taking away. And so this fun piece is important while we're
确实能给早期的关系注入那种能将其提升到新水平的连接感。有时候我们在人际关系中缺少的是乐趣。我们忘记了约会，虽然它是我们生活中的一件大事，但它应该是为了给我们的生活增添色彩，而不是减分。所以，在我们认真对待的同时，这部分的乐趣也很重要。
also being serious. Many of us, I'm sure I would be doing this too, especially after being a therapist so long. And I have moments of being too serious. I would show up, let's say it's me, I would show up to a date and be like, focus on sharing my intentions. But in this very very dry way. Like, this is what I'm looking for. What are you looking for? And I forget to, like, laugh, to joke about things or to people watch with them or talk about something funny I heard. And so, yeah, I'm just a strong believer these days in, like, loosening up and really enjoying the journey. It can feel counter when there are these hurts we experience along the way. I try to experience new relationships of all kinds as new relationships.
我们很多人，我敢说我以前也会这样，特别是当了这么长时间的治疗师之后。我也有过于严肃的时候。我会表现出，比方说换作是我，我会去约会，然后一心想着分享我的意图。但用一种非常非常枯燥的方式。比如，这就是我在找的。你在找什么？然后我忘了去笑，去开玩笑，或者和他们一起看路人，或者聊聊我听到的趣事。所以，是的，我如今坚信应该放松下来，真正享受这段旅程。当我们在这一路上经历这些伤害时，这可能会让人觉得与直觉相反。我试着把各种新的关系都当作是全新的关系来体验。
And so let them be new. That means let yourself be new and the new connections as well and have fun. And I remember you said something earlier that I loved, which was it should look a lot like a friendship. And like that's a huge part of friendship, right? It's like laughing and having fun with somebody and like experiencing joy and play. playing and like going on an adventure and like just being outdoors of whatever it is is also so important I think the other thing I would say is try and do daytime dates um daytime dates absolutely are you a big proponent of the daytime date I absolutely love that
所以，让它们保持新鲜。这意味着让自己保持新鲜，让新的连接也保持新鲜，并且要玩得开心。我记得你刚才说过的一句话我很喜欢，那就是它应该看起来很像友情。这也是友谊中很重要的一部分，对吧？就像和某人一起欢笑、享受乐趣，体验快乐和玩耍。玩耍、去冒险，或者只是到户外去，无论是什么，我也觉得非常重要。我想我要说的另一件事是，尽量安排白天的约会。嗯，白天的约会绝对是...你很支持白天的约会吗？我绝对超喜欢。
first of all some people we need to be going to sleep a little earlier uh some of are not getting enough rest. So I, and I am one of those people. Daytime, though, I have so much energy. Like, in the morning, I'm like dancing. I'm like, I'm loose. And so I think what you're getting at for me is like knowing yourself, knowing whether you're a morning person, a night person, and that can change depending on what your workload is or whatever. Go on dates when you can give your best. This is counter, though, I think, to a lot of the relationship conversations that are happening out there where people are like, don't take me on a breakfast date. I know.
首先，有些人我们需要早点睡觉，呃，有些人没有得到充足的休息。所以，我，我就是那种人。不过白天的时候，我精力充沛。比如，早上我会在跳舞。我感觉很放松。所以我觉得你对我的理解是，了解你自己，知道自己是早起型还是夜猫子，这可能会根据你的工作量或其他情况而有所改变。在你能发挥出最佳状态的时候去约会。不过，这我想与现今许多关于关系的讨论背道而驰，那些讨论中人们会说，不要带我去吃早餐约会。我知道。
But our report actually showed that the number one low pressure date spot for queer hinged daters was a coffee shop. So for queer daters, coffee shops are definitely places for solid connection. And I'm hoping more people, I think that could be for all daters without these kinds of stigmas attached to them. Oh, yeah. And I actually have a friend. her name is Chedera and she talks about this a lot and we definitely disagree on it.
但我们的报告实际上显示，对于酷儿 Hinge 约会者来说，压力最小的约会地点第一名是咖啡馆。因此，对于酷儿约会者来说，咖啡馆绝对是建立稳固连接的好地方。我希望更多的人，我认为这可以适用于所有约会者，而不用带上这些类型的污名。哦，是的。我其实有个朋友，她叫切德拉（Chedera），她经常谈论这个，我们对此确实有分歧。
I have a lot of love for her and she's always like, don't take me on a walk. A walk is not a day. Coffee is not a day and I was like, no, I totally get why you're saying that. But this is like when you already kind of know that you like the person. And also like in this economy, dinner and drinks is expensive. It's expensive. You end up being tired and then maybe you have a couple too many, like a few too many drinks, you're a bit drunk, you're a bit tipsy. Like, you're full, you're sleepy. It's like, and like during the daytime, it's like, that's how human hours. That's what I always say to people. Like, that's like the time when you're the most energized. Like, you can go outdoors and you can just like, even if it's wet and cold and rainy
我很喜欢她，她总是说，别带我去散步。散步不是约会。喝咖啡不是约会。我就说，不，我完全明白你为什么这么说。但这就像是你已经有点知道你喜欢这个人。而且在这个经济环境下，晚餐和酒水很贵。很贵。你最后会觉得累，然后可能你喝得有点多，喝了几杯多一点的酒，你有点醉了，有点微醺。就像，你吃饱了，你想睡觉。这就好比，在白天的时候，这就是人类的作息时间。这就是我经常对人们说的话。这就好像是你精力最充沛的时间。就像，你可以去户外，你可以就像，即使外面又湿又冷又下雨
and snowy, like, it creates play within us and it creates connection. But like, maybe I'll get DMs for people being like if somebody asked me how to like if somebody asked me to the park I would be saying absolutely no absolutely no way to that and I get it be safe but it could be a you know a picnic in the park um you know live music in the park maybe we have some qualifiers it could be like pretty cute uh and for anybody that's trying to decenter like maybe not decenter but trying to slow things down when it comes to physical relationships. Maybe they're the person that's often quick to a sexual relationship. I think daytime dates can naturally kind of shift that energy because we're so conditioned to think nighttime is sexy. And so when we go on daytime days, there are often even
还下着雪，这能在我们体内创造出玩耍的心态，并创造出连接。但也许我会收到网友的私信说，如果有人邀请我去公园，我绝对会说不，绝对没门。我理解，要注意安全，但它也可以是公园里的野餐，你知道的，公园里的现场音乐，也许我们有一些限定条件，它可能会相当可爱。对于任何想要淡化——也许不是淡化，而是试图在身体关系方面放慢节奏的人来说。也许他们是那种往往很快就发生性关系的人。我认为白天的约会可以很自然地转变这种能量，因为我们被灌输了夜幕降临就很性感的观念。所以当我们去白天约会时，通常甚至会有
time parameters on the days. Like we know we'll be together for a couple of hours and then we'll part ways. And so it kind of helps to put those natural boundaries. is in place if we are trying to be intentional about slowing down the physical connection. Well, there we go. There's the low pressure first date. Low pressure dates. Yeah. And I love what you.
约会的时间限制。就像我们知道我们会在一起几个小时，然后各奔东西。所以如果我们想刻意放慢身体关系的进展，它有助于建立这些自然的边界。好吧，这就是了。这就是低压力的第一次约会。低压力的约会。是的。我喜欢你说的那些。
Me too. And I love, like I will say me and Tom, my, like I keep saying Tom and then my partner. Hopefully by now they know his name. But something that was our second date was we went and had a picnic at, um, beautiful. This like beach lookout in the coast, like around the coast. of Australia. And we made it really fun where we were like, each of us has to bring like snacks and some food and a drink and, um, but we were like, it has to be something that we've never tried before. It was like the food that we, what that we bring is something that we've never
我也是。而且我喜欢，我会说我和汤姆，我的——我一直说汤姆，然后说我的伴侣。希望到现在他们已经知道他的名字了。但是我们的第二次约会是去野餐，嗯，太美了。在澳大利亚海岸附近的一个美丽的海滩瞭望台。我们把它弄得很有趣，我们规定，我们每个人都必须带上零食、一些食物和饮料，嗯，但我们说，这必须是我们从来没有尝试过的新东西。就像我们带的食物，我们以前从来没有
had something super strange or different or new. And it was like, okay, so like, yeah, we're outside. We were enjoying the sunshine, but then also like we had this like joint experience pretty early on. That was fun. Again, it was fun. It was like a bit different. And, maybe it's a bit lame to people, but I don't know, it worked for me. I'm still with him. He's like the love of my life. And like we actually got to know each other through those moments, which was really special. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. It's a beautiful example of thinking creatively about that low pressure day. But I would say like, and I would add that for anybody who's struggling to think that that's a quality day, think about the intention. Like what is it that you want to
吃过，是非常奇怪、不同或新鲜的东西。然后就觉得，好吧，我们在户外。我们享受着阳光，而且我们还在很早的时候就有了这种共同的体验。这很有趣。同样，这很有趣。这有点不同。而且，也许在别人看来这有点无聊，但不管怎样，对我有用。我还和他在一起。他就像是我一生的挚爱。我们实际上通过那些时刻了解了彼此，这真的很特别。是的。是的，绝对的。这是一个关于以创造性思维对待低压力约会的绝佳例子。但我要说的是，对于任何难以认为那是高质量约会的人，想想你的意图。比如你想从
what is it that you really want from the date? Sometimes I think people are focused on how much a person spends on the date as a measure of whether or not they're intentional or invested. And I think you can assess that investment in other ways. When you're on that beautiful picnic at this gorgeous beach lookout, how long they're staring into your eyes, how many smiles you exchange, how deeply they listen. send to your heartfelt stories from childhood, that all tells you that person is intentional. And so I want anybody listening to think about measuring this intention in a different way, because I think these early dates that are more low pressure could help us to communicate and engage in a different way.
约会中真正得到什么？有时我认为人们把一个人在约会上花多少钱作为衡量他们是否有意向或投入的标准。我认为你可以通过其他方式来评估这种投入。当你在这个 gorgeous（美丽的海滩）瞭望台上进行那场美妙的野餐时，他们凝视你眼睛的时间有多长，你们交换了多少微笑，他们多么认真地倾听你讲那些童年时期的心事，这一切都告诉你这个人是有意向的。所以我希望所有收听节目的听众考虑用不同的方式来衡量这种意向，因为我认为这些压力较小的前期约会可以帮助我们以不同的方式进行沟通和交流。
I think that is like the most beautiful sentiment to finish on. But actually, I do want to ask you why. more question aside from the slow manse, the slow burn, the low pressure first dates, I feel like we've been very much like take it slow and make it last. What would be your other biggest piece of advice for dating in your 20s? Oh, I'm so happy you ask because earlier in the year, Hinge released the Gen Z day report. So if anybody listening has not seen that, I encourage you to go check that out. The Gen Z date report, uh, the Gen Z date report, uh, actually uncovered that 90% of Gen Z hinged daters are actually looking for love, but their collective
我觉得这是最美好的结束语。但实际上，我确实想问你另外一个问题，除了慢恋爱、慢热、低压力初次约会之外，感觉我们一直在强调慢下来并让它持久。对于二十多岁的约会，你最大的其他建议是什么？哦，我很高兴你问这个，因为在今年早些时候，Hinge 发布了 Z 世代约会报告。所以如果有任何收听节目的朋友还没有看过，我鼓励大家去看看。Z 世代约会报告，嗯，Z 世代约会报告，实际上发现 90% 的 Z 世代 Hinge 约会者其实都在寻找真爱，但他们共同的
worries around rejection were actually getting in the way, preventing them from initiating these really important conversations or even talking to the people that they like. And so my advice for anyone dating in their 20s are these three things. First, embrace cringe mode. So if something feels cringy, if you're worried about rejection, my advice is to embrace. this feeling because it's just telling you that what you're really wanting is connection and we should prioritize what we want over what we don't want. That's how we create what we want. So then the second thing that I encourage you to do is to be upfront in your digital body
对拒绝的担忧实际上成了阻碍，阻止他们发起这些非常重要的对话，甚至不敢和自己喜欢的人说话。所以我给二十多岁约会者的建议是这三点。首先，拥抱尴尬模式。所以如果有什么事情感觉很尴尬，如果你担心被拒绝，我的建议是拥抱这种感觉，因为这只是在告诉你，你真正想要的是连接，我们应该把我们想要的东西放在我们不想要的东西之前。这就是我们创造我们想要的东西的方式。那么我鼓励你做的第二件事就是在你的数字身体
language. People in their 20s are way more keenly aware of deciphering, at deciphering text messages, emojis, what people mean when they're not saying anything, what those dots mean when they appear and they go away, all of their things. So we're calling that DBL at Hinge. That stands for digital body language. I encourage people in their 20s to just be very clear about your own DBL, what you're communicating, when you're not actually communicating, what you're communicating with those emojis, all of the things, all the subtle cues that you're sending. because the more clear that you can be, the more of the good vibes that you're sending out to other people.
语言中表现得坦诚。二十多岁的人对解读短信、表情符号、人们不说话时意味着什么、那些点出现又消失时意味着什么，以及所有这些事情，有着更敏锐的觉察。所以在 Hinge，我们称之为 DBL。这代表数字身体语言（digital body language）。我鼓励二十多岁的人明确你自己的 DBL，你正在传达什么，当你没有真正交流时你在传达什么，你用那些表情符号传达了什么，所有这些事情，你发出的所有微妙线索。因为你越明确，你向其他人传递的良好氛围就越多。
And then the third thing would be to, I don't want you to be afraid anymore to initiate those conversations around like, what are we? If you're really wanting to know where a relationship is going, somebody has to make that first step. And what we found in the Gen Zee Day report is that people are waiting
然后第三件事就是，我不想让你再害怕主动发起关于“我们算什么”的对话。如果你真的很想知道一段关系走向何方，总得有人迈出第一步。我们在 Z 世代约会报告中发现的是，人们都在等待
for the other person to do it. So we need to go ahead and just make it known that if you make that initiative, very likely there's someone on the other end of that waiting to have had that conversation too. Oh my gosh, absolutely. Spot on. I just want to say thank you again for coming on and for sharing your amazing insights. This was actually just also such a fun conversation. You are so wise. And you just like brought such a fun energy to dating, which sometimes we don't have. You know, sometimes it feels very serious. So, Mo, where can they find you? Where can they follow you? Where can they hear more from you?
另一个人来做这件事。所以我们需要继续前进，让别人知道，如果你迈出了第一步，很可能在终端的某个人也在等待着进行那次对话。哦，天哪，绝对是这样。太对了。我只是想再次感谢你来到节目并分享你精彩的见解。实际上这也是一场非常有趣的对话。你太有智慧了。你给约会带来了非常有趣的能量，有时我们并不具备这种能量。你知道，有时它感觉非常严肃。那么，莫，大家可以在哪里找到你？在哪里可以关注你？在哪里可以听到你更多的分享？
Yay. Thank you so much for having me. I can be found on Instagram at Love Out Proud. So check me out at Love Out Proud. I also co-host a podcast with my wife called Be Your Own Love Goals podcast with Moiree and Tiffany. And you can check us out on all the major streaming platforms, but we're also on Instagram at Be Your Own Love Goals. So if you want to check out some cute couples content, you want more lifestyle advice things for me. Please connect with me on social media. I love, you know, connecting with people and I'm looking forward to it. I really hope that they do. And I'm actually really keen to go and listen to your podcasts now.
耶。非常感谢邀请我。大家可以在 Instagram 上找到我，账号是 Love Out Proud。所以快来看看我的 Love Out Proud 账号吧。我还和我的妻子共同主持一个播客，叫做《Be Your Own Love Goals podcast with Moiree and Tiffany》（莫莉和蒂凡尼的做你自己的恋爱目标播客）。你可以在各大主流流媒体平台上找到我们，我们也在 Instagram 上，账号是 Be Your Own Love Goals。所以如果你想看一些可爱的伴侣内容，想要我提供更多生活方式方面的建议。请在社交媒体上与我联系。我喜欢，你知道的，与人联系，我很期待。我真的很希望他们会这么做。而且我实际上现在真的很想去听听你的播客。
I feel like I could do some more like wise, fun advice. Well, thank you again to our lovely guest. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give a third. five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, it really helps the show to grow and reach new people. If there was someone who needs advice on slowing things down, maybe poignly, maybe not so poignantly, send them this episode, they might benefit from it. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you maybe disagree with our advice or you agree very highly, please shoot me a message at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you.
我觉得我可以做更多像这样充满智慧、有趣的建议。好吧，再次感谢我们的可爱嘉宾。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方给出一个五星好评，这真的有助于节目的成长并接触到新的人。如果有谁需要关于放慢脚步的建议，也许一针见血，也许不那么一针见血，把这期节目发给他，他们可能会从中受益。如果你对节目有建议，或者你可能不同意我们的建议，又或者非常赞同，请在那个心理学播客给我发信息。我很乐意听到你的反馈。
And until then, stay safe. Be kind. And of course, be gentle to. yourself and we will talk very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
在此之前，注意安全。保持善良。当然，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会聊。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字是数字的 TWO percent，在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. You got your podcast. I got you.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的地方。找到你想要的。我懂你。
On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。
84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
84 年是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证真人。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。